[Music]
throughout
2020 the european parliament pushed
member states to accept an ambitious 1.1
trillion euro budget
to fund eu projects for the next seven
years
2021 should see it come into force on
top of this the eu's 750 billion euro
recovery fund
will begin investing in people jobs and
industries
parliament will examine key green deal
legislation
reducing vehicle emissions protecting
biodiversity
and preparing industry for a carbon
neutral future
europe wants to become a world leader in
digital technologies and artificial
intelligence
upcoming legislation will shape the eu's
digital strategy
build an ethical framework for ai and
invest in research and development
the migration crisis that peaked in 2015
and 2016
exposed shortcomings of the eu asylum
and migration system
parliament will examine a raft of
measures to guarantee the safety of
people in need of protection
while ensuring countries at the eu's
external borders
are not overburdened how do you imagine
the future
shape of the eu 2021 will see the
conference on the future of europe bring
together ordinary citizens
civil society and stakeholders to debate
ideas
policy and the direction of the union
eu-wide action is critical during health
emergencies
parliament will thrash out the new eu
for health program which will help
prepare for future health threats
address medicine shortages and focus on
disease prevention